بعد اربعين عاما غدر كريم يونس المعتقل
الاسرائيلي بدات مرحله جديده من التوتر في
حياه كريم ومن بقي من ذويه بالاضافه الى
65 اسيرا اخرين من داخل الخط الاخضر
التوتر والقلق الجديد يتمثل في قرار
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي سحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه مما يحملها من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين قبل ان تتشكل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده كان الملف على طاوله
اطراف الائتلاف الحكومي الاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل اتفقت الاطراف على هذا
القانون الذي سيبعد بموجبه هؤلاء الاسرى
من مدنهم داخل الخط الاخضر الى مناطق
سيطره السلطه الفلسطينيه يضاف الى هؤلاء
الاسرى اكثر من 400 اسير من القدس المحتله
ستعاملهم اسرائيل وفق هذا القانون
تمت تفاصيل مهمه في فهم ما سيحدث يحمل
الفلسطينيون داخل فلسطين التاريخيه ثلاثه
انواع من الوثائق داخل الخط الاخضر يحملون
بطاقه هويه وجواز سفر اسرائيليين وهم في
هذه الحاله نظريا مواطنون اسرائيليون لهم
الحقوق وعليهم الواجبات لم يغادروا بيوتهم
ابانا النكبه ويبلغ عددهم الان مليون و600
الف فلسطيني تعتقل اسرائيل 65 منهم نفذوا
عمليات ضد الاحتلال واغلبهم حكم عليه
بالمؤبد معرضون الان لسحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه والطرد الى مناطق السلطه في
الضفه او غزه
في القدس المحتله قرابه مئه الف فلسطيني
الحديث هنا عن القدس التي احتلتها اسرائيل
عام 67 ولم تنسحب منها مع اتفاق اوسلو هي
القدس القديمه ومحيطها يحمل الفلسطينيون
هنا بطاقه اقامه مؤقته في اسرائيل وجواز
سفر اردنيا مؤقتا كذلك لان الاردن هي
صاحبه الوصايه على الاماكن المقدسه وكانت
تحكم هذه المنطقه هؤلاء ليسوا مواطنين
اسرائيليين ولا مواطنين اردنيين ولا
يحملون ما يثبت فلسطينتهم بالوثائق معرضون
الان لسحب هذه الاقامه المؤقته والطرد
كذلك الى مناطق الضفه او غزه بجوار هؤلاء
قرابه ثلاثه ملايين فلسطيني في الضفه
الغربيه ومليوناني في قطاع غزه يحمل هؤلاء
بطاقته هويه وجواز سفر اصدرتهما السلطه
الفلسطينيه عقب انشائها عام 93 تعتقد
اسرائيل اكثر من اربعه منهم وعندما يفرج
عنهم يغادرون الى بيوتهم او يبعد من تصفهم
اسرائيل بالخاطرين الى غزه او خارج البلاد
بالعوده الى ما بات يعرف بالمقدسيين
وفلسطينيين داخل تتحكم اسرائيل فيما
يحملون من وثائق بالاصدار والتمديد او
الالغاء الحجه الامنيه حاضره على الدواء
هكذا تتبخر كل الوثائق التي يحملها
الفلسطينيون تحت سلطه الاحتلال يحكم عليهم
بقوانين تصدر لتحافظ على الائتلافات
الحكوميه وتطرفها وليس بقوانين تصدر من
دوله طبيعيه تتكون من ارض وشعب